hello welcome to this video this is
coverage for the London chefs classic
the third and final lack of the grand
chest or yeah this is the first round
and jung i'll be covering this event by
going through all the games quickly no
but focusing on maybe one or two key
games of the rounded it depends a little
bit how the games go with there are two
or three super interesting games okay
i'll be going into those a little bit in
a little bit more detail we will see
what happens okay in this round I'll be
kicking off with Caruana with white
playing Aronian yeah because you know
pests which was to be expected koalas
almost exclusively playing 1.e4 at their
own jana yeah this is a permanent 105
player so we probably could have got
guests that opening beforehand so what
do we get aronian um played three a six
and probably angling for the marshal as
he usually does but karana went for one
of those entire marshal lines we had
some fairly standard development and the
white Bishop going to a to know Bishop
to e6 yeah this is some the same
position that both players had in 2004
14 when kawana decided to take and play
before that happened in the sink filled
cup 2014 when kawana won a nice game
later those part of his seven-game
winning streak this time however he
plays a different movie plays deform hmm
quite logical actually striking in the
center with blacks night being offside
on a 5 this is quick quickly and get
changed by aronia and getting the night
back and supporting the center here
if I upon yeah here I actually thought
that white might be able to hold the
center a little bit before releasing the
attention but I mean what can go with
with slow moves like Age 3 or rookie one
or something like that just keep their
keep the center but he decided to play
if I a d5 probably also because they
look on a2 is quite a funny spot so
opening up the position maybe not that
mm not in the whites interest so much
yeah back to the be eight and this is a
good regrouping Knight to d7 and then
the Queen to be seven yeah what about
this position equal slightly better
Hawaii have to say I think probably pink
black should be okay even though black
as I'm reduced to one particular idea
for some kind of played that would be
the move c6 now you have to pawn leave
us here c 6 + f5 f5 seems entirely
unrealistic to play and therefore c6 is
the move that black will go for even
though and we will see that later this
weekend's a little bit we've got an
interesting moment here night h to the
idea that white orphan has is to play
Knight to g4 this especially applies
especially applies to position like that
let's say something like that where this
move can be interesting to trade nights
the knight on f6 is defending the g5
square so trading the f 39 which does
not relate to the d5 square or can be
useful interesting idea night h to him
but it's a well-known idea anticipating
the c6 move yeah aronian went age five
just covering this square a difficult
move to play I think age five I would be
reluctant to to play it that much I can
I can tell but it does make quite a bit
of sense of
cause ya back to f3 now that this idea
was some was nullified Bishop g5 this is
also in anticipation of the c6 break we
will see why because now white is able
to capture that night which defended the
d5 square so it looks like Wyatt gets
this scenario of a favorable night
against the bad be sure the bishop that
is just protecting that pawn looks like
a dummy p is only seven but it is not
that bad because the night on a three
well it is on f3 and not on d5 this is
the main thing here if white like
magically could transfer the night to
the d5 square he definitely would be um
yeah in a good in a good to situation
having some advantage but it's not so
easy to get down yeah it's it's four
moves and it's difficult to do probably
impossible and this means that black is
it seems to be perfectly okay we'll see
how it how it goes there's the counter
plane a 50 + B form yeah and I don't
really see something better than what
kawana did here and trade it in plate
see form otherwise if he takes he's
settled with them somewhat settled I
think it's a record with the week be
born so he went see form and again that
doesn't look good but I thing is black
is easily trading things and now it's
even ready for that typical regrouping
of the bishop and I will see that is in
no way inferior to the noise here we go
now the bishop is doing a good job in
defending yeah I mean white shouldn't do
this
intone and after the trade happened
absolutely nothing is going on in a
couple of more moves and here the
position is so blocked that really any
absolutely all players in the world now
would draw with either color because you
cannot even make a mistake anymore so
I'm a very clean draw it felt like
around here that maybe white can do
something with them relatively good
night against the bishop but it felt
like ultimately the night does not come
to I'm sorry for that the night yet does
not come to defy ever i cannot paint it
and this means that black is going to
equalize okay let's go to the next game
on mdl with white against the world
champion magnus carlsen what do we get
is Sicilian okay well cousin is mostly
in 105 player but he mixes it up a
little bit with the Sicilian now and
then and the line he goes for his
situation it off it's something that he
has played before most notably if we
look at them very very top level games
he played it in them in the second leg
of the grand Chester against tarnish
Geary we get the main line there's
really not much to do up to this point
it's pretty much forced once especially
cause on the board and here MVR goes for
the bishop f6 line or let's say 95 /
should have 6 line the other principal
choice is to take in new 95 here which
is a little bit sharper yeah damaging
the pawn structure but giving black
dynamic ideas so this is the morn let's
say a strategic move castles now by
Carson he played 97 against Giri but
Castle is there is the main movement
decision or Bishop g5 those moves I have
played myself in fact it's been a while
but i played this where she called quite
a bit ok castles um 92 would be a tall
this is some very very common and the
next whatever bye um maxima sheila graph
is a bit surprising he played the a form
move here right away and after a long
thinking we can see here the clock he
took like no more than 15 minutes or
what it said yeah and 60 minutes for the
move which is pretty amazing considering
that we are talking about a complete an
absolute main line of a very popular
opening so maybe he confused his
preparation or forgot something when you
should play move quickly there i mean
the thing is some a4 is not even that
great the normal museum are either
developing something like this should be
to let's say well there is this funny
idea h4 h4 looks like a strange idea
what is the point of that that flank
pawn there are a couple of ideas in some
but rare cases it's even the starting
point of some kind of attack here with
live chief mahadji five but this is the
rare case the more common idea is to
cover g5 so that there is no Bishop g5
why is Bishop g5 a move because white
often puts this night you should
probably on paint this white often puts
it knight to e three supporting his
friend on d5 and then black quite often
is not unhappy to play Bishop g5 and
trade of that night to lessen why its
control of the d5 square this is
prevented by H 4 and the second idea is
that g3 and Bishop h3 can be an
interesting concept trading off or
trying to trade the light squared
bishops which in turn would help us
white
to be yeah more secure on the d5 square
so that the night cannot easily be
challenged but there should be six is
that bishop is traded now all those
moves are more critical especially h4
but a 4 was played by maxim and the
issue is black is just taking this yeah
it's not waiting till white captures on
b5 but of course he takes and makes use
of the open V file night before now and
takes and takes yeah if white takes with
the night Bishop e7 is already a bit
inconvenient note that white has not
cashed out yet black is better developed
and this can easily be a problem now
this is hanging and if white covers
something like a 59 c to d 5 c's wide on
the ropes already so anyway I porn down
even but the pure the strategic factors
alone are bad enough so white has to
take with a pawn there is no big choice
there and now Bishop e7 yeah just
looking at that and at night on d5 and
trying to just take it Luke takes a form
and now Queen c8 was played um it's an
interesting a moment here black also
could have taken on d5 and maybe that
was a somewhat more interesting choice
this is at least given by about the
engine something like ed 584 is
interesting they are activating the
bishop and if the Queen takes black into
something like green tea seven winning
oops that was the wrong arrow attacking
that taking that rook and something like
okay six route before it's definitely
not bad for blanket
even though something like Bishop c4
shouldn't travel why too much I mean if
we look at this like here and so maybe
root is six and then castles that should
still end in a draw where this was
played by by carlson and now yeah mvl
took on f6 yet damaging the pawn
structure check ticks and ticks and
Bishop d3 and now White's counterplay
ideas too yeah go for the king okay six
and Bishop c6 and rook takes before yeah
and now here the thing is I mean Black
has play here against you for and be too
but blacks king is also yeah in a tough
spot the conclusion of the game here
with them rooty for its pretty much
force now queena three f6 is hanging and
I mean black doesn't really want to to
cover that a screen g35 king age 8 and
something that [ __ ] see one is more than
awkward and cousin decided to take here
and this ends the game basically to a
draw and I think maybe I mean he didn't
have a great alternative yeah but also
we should keep in mind that in the first
two events of that grandchester I mean
cards and lost his first game here the
first game in Norway he lost on time in
the winning position where he forgot the
time control it was kind of a kind of
crazy and the other game he lost to
topple off both both games he lost the
ins Apollo he lost against Apollo with
white when some well-known novelty was
sprung on him and he lost a pretty bad
game so maybe he was some not too
dissatisfied with the draw anyway so
we got this situation now made thread on
age seven so black has to take on the
form yeah now white of course is not
settling for this yeah where you have to
fight the pawn down I go here check and
tragic check and it's a perpetual again
a very correct draw I think and a little
bit you have the consequence of yeah mvl
playing um get a non-critical ID on move
move 13 even though i think that Carlton
probably yeah maybe should have tried to
take on d5 here instead of Quincy eight
but ultimately we shouldn't forget if
your cheek here we also get opposite
colored bishops which it's not like this
is a drawer so because of the opposite
color bishops but the pure nature of the
position even if black let's say get
those porns here for the a6 pawn if
white puts the bishop 125 yeah you can
be a pawn down yeah it doesn't matter at
all then the [ __ ] pawn on d6 is
completely unimportant so it's difficult
for black to get get anywhere here ok so
let's look at the next game and hunt
with white against Micky Adams the local
player Adams is not a regular a member
of this grand chest to a band of players
but he's the local local guy from London
um of course he's a very strong end and
it could play from the terms of his
abilities but he has no one um the games
in the first two legs and is not
competing for the overall standings so
we'll see what happens allen went when
see for that it's not happening that
often in vicious games he's mostly an e4
player even though he had his moments of
course of d for him he played deform
famously against crumb Nick in his best
match of his life in 2008 and he also
played them d 4 in the odd crucial game
against
against Carlton see for whatever is not
seen that often in ireland's games but
he has played against Adams only am this
yen in Schanke and um gosh IAM of
memoria where are not one a very nice
game but with the English opening this
was also played in Enchantia but um
Adams went for some c6 base set up in
that event there's something like and
like like this happened and somewhat
yeah i think we had this position or
something very very similar and i loved
one a nice game with white this time
Mickey just goes 45 this is the the main
line and it's basically a reverse dragon
and three year check this position it is
just like the dragon variation but with
reverse colors what is the big
difference the big difference is that in
the in the regular dragon variation very
often right in this case it would be
black there as it is kind of servers
castles long form a very sharp play
where where the king is sitting on c8
and age 5 h for something like that
would happen with color servers but it's
not doable here with them yeah black
being a tempo tempo down why isn't this
working black being a tempo down
compared to the colors of your situation
here black has to be content with that
classical set up with Bishop g7 and
castles one reason is by the way if you
want to really explain that in some
detail is that for that long castling
set up to work um black in the first
place would need to avoid that night
move so it would need to play this move
but the issue is if we really I'm trying
to go there like I have 6 and 3g seven
then castles here white has to move 184
and this is a much much better thing
then black can ever hope for in the
regular dragon variation as there is in
early d six plays in the
seems like d4 in one move and white is
also why I'm having an extra temple so
fantastic situation for wide black has
to settle for that strategically focused
set up with Bishop e7 and short castles
yeah on argos form this setup d3 Bishop
e3 Roxy one this is a basically
forgotten line if you compare it to what
was on vogue in the last couple of years
or if you yeah I mean you can even
extend it to like let's say the last two
decades where everybody basically went
for 83 and b4 setups that look see one
Bishop e3 was popular back in the 1960s
um and even back then it didn't have a
reputation of being very dangerous I
think this has been seen a little bit
more often in recent times but this game
is no great advertisement for for white
set up to be honest black puts the
knight on d4 which is the usual way of
playing and you develop your pieces
rupee eight Bishop f8 and then night up
to deform and this is the general
problem with many dragon type of setups
whenever a night pops up on that square
you're either forced to tolerate that
piece to take it or to kick it away if
you kick it away with III which is of
course impossible right yes this Bishop
there but if you play you three against
that night you would weaken your porn on
d3 often tricky decision not easy to
play getting that pawn week all you have
to take let's say let's say for example
what would take you yeah cakes and cakes
and now we see that this rook all of a
sudden is of a nice half open file and
that point only two could prove ulnar
about so also not a decision that is so
easy to make so you can take and give
him the app open file you can play III
so what are you going to do you're going
to tolerate the night
yeah in this particular game are not
ignored the night for the time being but
yeah no animals could have maintained it
a little bit but he decided to relatives
and quickly trade it off in order to get
a new heights to d5 and put up the
position like that we see that black is
very nicely centralized and the night on
a four is not doing that much yeah black
setup is very harmonious and it's
unclear what white is doing that I mean
where are you attacking there is no weak
pawn or a clear weakness that you can
focus your pieces on yeah in the game we
had some trades coming yeah blackest I
think well it was to simply take this
the night is potentially the more
dangerous PCM as the position is
relatively closed I mean we're not
talking about a closed closed position
but the night is some certainly able to
maybe maneuver to Goods good squares if
you imagine for example something like
94 and g4 could establish the night on
the Foursquare if why this given time so
what what Adams did is a simple solution
you just took the Nile and fifty put the
parents if I I'm sorry for that alright
that was the mailman what can you do
okay so black plate c5 and putting up on
a position that is kind of comparable to
a maraca see behind here with those two
points and now it's very difficult for y
to do anything yeah III d for tough to
play before also tough to play so we
have a position here that is yeah very
very balanced let's say
why does some having a little bit of a
space disadvantage but black is some is
not able to do much there they are yeah
repeated right here I think again a very
correct game and in the solid to draw
here for Adams with black to be
perfectly honest this line own if we go
back here this is the solid line is one
of the reasons why I myself don't play
one see for more often I sometimes play
that move but this is a very difficult
to do anything with wide against you
with the with this kind of reverse the
dragon next position is extremely
extremely sound and solid and white has
some very little that you can do to make
some kind of substantial pressure and
like with some kind of somewhat forced
to line where you can get a little
something it's just not there I mean the
position is very solid for black so one
can be very much recommended for black
players this kind of setup even if you
are not a 15 player yeah I mean I wonder
sorry 1.e4 player yeah you could say
that well what black is doing is
basically playing Annie for opening with
colors reverse mm-hmm is that a good
idea if I never play one you falls right
yeah i think it is it is a very specific
kind of position that you can learn it's
not like you're all of a sudden have to
change your whole personality to play
this kind of position ok so that was the
third draw and now we come to two games
that were a bit more interesting let's
aim um let's go form where's the game
shouldn't miss click here agree shock
with white against Nakamura so what do
we get yeah a Berlin yeah the days of
nakum who are playing an ya unsound
openings definitely over it's having a
very very sore
it sound repertoire nowadays really
plays the odd Kings Indian or Dutch
defense or so but he also plays Berlin
and Queens gambit declined Lasker and in
this kind of thing and yeah it's a way
to go if you want to become the world
champion and this is definitely what he
wants to do so we got the Berlin defense
and we shook and allows the end game he
both plays d3 and the endgame variation
but he's one of the guys who is more
often than not going for this end game
which is still probably the more
principled choice than playing at one of
the the slowish lines ok I'm not going
to make a big theoretical server here on
the Berlin Wall endgame simply because
I'm not qualified I can only do one a
couple of things here here or remark a
couple of things we shall played the
move King h2 which is a new mu hasn't
been played before and in the press
conference I saw a little bit of the
coverage um yesterday um he said that um
Nakamura now found the best reply but it
is something that is not so easy to do
over the board yeah Nakamura alexia he
had blitzed up to here but and he took
like really 40 minutes and then when c5
this is a tough move to play because it
is such a committal choice yeah you play
c5 force the night bay city to be five
and then play King the aid again
remember that black had taken on the
eight back to e8 now back to d8 what is
the the point behind all those of those
King moves it's very concrete the night
now is on b5 and if Black gets in an
attack on that night the White Knight
has to drop back to a3 which is an
absolutely terrible square and in
comparison we look here in comparison
that time loss by the black king is far
less important
the night on a three is just completely
misplaced and it doesn't have something
great to go to okay can go to see
forward and it's not really helping that
much white has lost lots of time with
this night and in comparison I think
black is quite quite happy with this
King move again okay not your form and
age five Bishop c6 that Bishop has
activated we should never forget that
black has the bishop pair and if why
does not getting anywhere with this
majority black will often be just better
and this is what what happened in the
game a very nice moment is here after
have four nakamura displayed the moose
f5 it's also not such a completely easy
decision to make giving white a
protected passed pawn a 35-point however
that pawn is not going to be promoting
anytime soon and on the other hand what
black is getting is the potential of
getting in Knight to f5 if the G and F
porn are traded note that the capture
and it's no good idea something like
this for example leaves white in some
substantial trouble yeah night f5 is
already a threat and yeah the head King
it's not good at all again note how bad
this night is on a three so this was
better better move by back we show but
after 96 my camera found a good move f
takes d4 that's very nice 96 was a
mistake I guess because after check this
now white is in some trouble right f5
check is a is a huge threat check e 6
was played if white takes the rook in
the corner nashik five check is going to
win immediately you know the first line
that we have to check it
checkmate is this so why has to go back
but now there's a check coming here and
something like that white will
absolutely not survive here we've got
the check on both rocks and yeah what is
why it's supposed to play and something
like d8 for example Black is going here
and here we see the big threat Bishop e7
is some gap winning winning everything
the rook and probably with a check made
to come yeah I note how backpacking
places tonight so it's really pretty
remarkable so white cannot take the rook
he asserted this check kingi eight
instead of course you you cannot take it
it's the same line one here it's a
little bit more complicated if we want
to check this check check yeah that's
nice but what are you going to do now
just here i am possible to prevent white
cannot take the rook what to teach you
it took that porn on g4 rugae seven
saving the root for the moment and now
look d7 funny funny move by Brie shocked
but you had to I mean then I just
wrapped wipes position is really in some
some danger of falling apart just now
Rock t7 whatever it says putting up a
good fight I can now play tonight f5 we
of course have to check what happens if
he takes the rook if you take the rook
and pawn takes why this of course
threatening to promote so night here and
now it's an interesting moment here
White has 98 or 95 something like night
e8 is threatening Knight f6 in some
cases and also yeah I mean threatens
Knight f6 if white takes on the 7th
the way I should should raise it and it
prepares rookie one so let's say b5
route d1 and why it is still very much
in the game there should be seven and
now white even has weird looking boobs
like before trying to exploit this
pinning situation while it's definitely
somehow fighting so nakamura played 95
that's also the strongest move the night
is approaching the king and of course
threatening big bishop have to know
check check yeah we're repeating when
being low on time is a is a good idea
and now Bishop e7 bring that into the
game and cutting away important squares
rooked you one that's a relatively best
defense it shouldn't save but it still
them still the best try check again we
have check a repetition and here's the
moment we're probably Nakamura could
have won the game with the move rogue
age five it's a nice little preparation
move then threatens night h6 check king
g3 bishop age for winning the house and
it seems that ultimately white is not
able to defend against that for example
if whites cheeks on yourself this is
something that is almost a young
mandatory then root G check King h7
again white can try this funny movie we
have sacrificed to exchange em and it's
this this this is a is a funny line all
of a sudden introducing this idea but
blackheads whoop Dee fire and this will
win a nice little thing is that after
night see for black should play the move
rupees
and not just take on d 7 yeah again this
is this year don't fall into that just
go here and see what white is coming up
now black black will win this is a very
good opportunity here Luke age five but
Nakamura couldn't yeah I know he he
probably didn't like a particular line
or was irritated about something yeah
and he decided to oops I'm sorry to play
the check again and now go Luke age
seven and here after night see for the
activation of the of the night um yeah
seems to save the day for white if black
now try something I like taking things
are not clear at all because there are a
number of options now for wide yes some
95 for example some 95 what position all
of a sudden is very active so taking the
exchange was no option ultimately with
no time on the clock they play two hours
forty moves with or without any
increment nakamura decided to go for the
repetition here yeah it's not the most
inspiring thing to do but we have no
time on the clock what are you doing so
taking the joy is probably the the wise
decision um of course um spoiled chance
for now come around for an early early
even in this event but it was a it was a
very tricky difficult game and showing
that there are some interesting games in
the Berlin Wall end game it's not always
a doubt draw quite often however okay so
we've got one game left to check and
this is top off with white against
unleash Giri so let's go for that
so what do we have in this game Geary
seems to go for a groom for defense it's
not Kings Indian play at least not on
that level usually going for the gruene
felt if you if he goes for a g6 base set
up in the first place and to part of
course for d3 he's got an interesting
idea in mind giving place the c6 g5 fly
this is the most solid way to play
against the fianchetto variation of the
green side and outer part of goes for a
2920 to a 4 i'm somewhat strange at
first looking move why move out a way to
move out the Queen early the idea is
that if black is playing routinely mark
Bishop g7 then after ctx night x white
has at least avoided a scenario where
the sea porn recaptures on d5 a scenario
that is often pretty dull to be honest
yeah but the open sea file a little bit
comparable to them to slough exchange
which is also not the most exciting
opening ever so Queen a4 is a very
concrete idea the idea of capturing on
d5 so what did give we do you play
tonight f.2d 7 look strange but it is
quite a quite a good idea ideas to
threaten night to be 6 and to provoke or
to go for this kind of position yeah so
the white queen is going to a forehead
back and in the meantime black has
rebooted his night from f6 to be 6 it's
not so badly placed on be sick so I
don't really believe that white set up
is that that terribly dangerous so we
had a couple of normal-looking moves
rook e8 b3 and now we five this
an important idea that is useful to
remember here the isolated pawn is no
problem at all blacks activity is very
very substantial and quite often it's
got ideas like Bishop f5 and putting a
piece on d3 note that why it is not able
to take on d5 as something like this
this and later here will pick up
material that the bishop is on that on
that rook white cannot take the point
you should be content with development
developing pieces and this is what two
part of deity first to control over g4
we should have 594 and Bishop d3 and
tier 93 is a is an idea yeah the power
of now went for own this move it looks
kind of weird but it's a bit difficult
to suggest something else you have to
look at this 93 rupee 2nite see one
threat to see the reason and norman was
like Bishop b2 and they just don't cut
it doesn't look right like here and here
but it's not a problem at all Queen d2
as is a decent move we want to
ultimately fianchetto 93 in our bishop
deform interesting decision and just
hacking this hacking this piece but
black gets very active play now Queen to
have six and taking on deform yeah how
to evaluate this position and the
computer is pretty positive that this is
this is equal but it is all about one
particular situation 97 room a form 2595
and here here Gary took 1 C 1 and
now while this position is rather
complicated yeah and I'm a little bit in
the time Harry here so I don't want to
look at all possible lines but it seems
that here Gibby could have equalized
with night seven to see five leading to
very complicated stuff for example rook
age 4 is an interesting tribe which
sometimes is the pre due to something
like Queen to h6 yeah tix for example
primanti expecially two very very
complicated lines Quincy five and Bishop
d1a six yeah it's a it's a big mess but
it seems that black ultimately is ok
with that with that kind of position the
issue was that he took on c1 and here
it's a little bit difficult now to fend
off the ideas especially 97 he went here
and here and to part of could have
played um stronger than he did he played
the move Knight c7 that ultimately
doesn't lead to much it seems that if
white takes him I am sorry if what does
look at thought that was my line here
ook at four then White has a better
position taking Andrew care for is also
interesting but something like that
that's what I'm the what i was looking
at now here have seven is under big
pressure and also be seven is still
under fired by the bishop on d5 here
give you would have had a hard time to
to get a draw at at the end not easy at
all not easy at all to play in step 2
power of plate 92 c7 and roop the aid of
course it's nowhere it's no fork like a
swoop the aid weather with the temple
and queen a four and now g5
now why it keeps the Queen's Own
something like 25 rookie five it's
ultimately not not so dangerous after g5
keeping the Queen's on makes an awful
lot of sense in general and this was
completely okay played here by both
players the critical moment comes a
little bit later age six cover on g500
this is fine Bishop f3 yeah and now
Aguirre plays a strong move he plays
Knight to e5 and this is a strong move
because of two reason is the only move
in some way and it also yeah comes with
a pretty nice trap tapar off is down to
about two minutes no increment and now
has two decides what to do the thing is
it is very obvious to probably about yea
or all players I let's say if white is
just taking this rook takes and then
some normal move I mean maybe you taking
on a seven I was uh yeah you can just do
here here and this is never going to be
bad for white yeah you can nah not this
one but today we're looking okay one you
can do yeah Queen at five something is
just going to be a draw nothing nothing
will happen here a top part of certainly
saw that of course he's a great player
them but the thing is there is also a
different possibility and this is 19
it's a queen takes a seven and first of
all first you think oh wait isn't that
good for Wyatt yeah the rook doesn't
have many squares to go and it has to
cover the e4 night so what is black
supposed to do something like this
probably not nice rocky one
the thing is black has a move and it is
this move Knight takes f to it at first
it's not clear why this should work at
all because Bishop e2 check check yeah
and now we come to that to the point if
white is now you played king of one of
course but if he goes Here I am then
childlike takes and now has the
multitude and there's Queen age five
mate and white funny enough has no way
to defend against the mating attack
absolutely no way if white is going back
here check check check mate it's an even
quicker and so white has to play King
everyone is absolutely only move and
here well black is a rope down right
yeah he is a rock down but he has this
great Queen t5 and this is threatening
made in two moves and the amazing thing
is then white is just entirely lost here
it is just a complete loss white cannot
defend against this attack very sudden
turn of events in some way and very
nicely planned ahead by Geary i think
it's it's pretty easy to see that like
here you have a have a threat okay yeah
but it is not easy to to calculate
especially with that limited time
available then white has no defense here
yeah to pull off what did you try he
played Bishop H fire but let's say you
would go to you won and that is looking
like a pretty logical try and try out
the defense yeah blackjack
and then back and now the threaded
screen takes g3 check White has little
moves yeah let's say but should be to
check and rook 26 it all works perfectly
no defense whatsoever yeah whoops III
check check check check check and picks
up the rook it's really remarkable why
it has no defenses a rook up and it
doesn't look so terribly and coordinated
but it is simply not holding not at all
yeah this is what to pile of droid
bishop h5 looking at the f7 pawn he only
had one minute left it didn't matter it
was lost already but check Quincy to
check check check check yeah I know Jack
White's king is hunted down for
checkmate here to pile of resigned I
guess he resigned you I didn't lose on
time it's made now yeah the King has to
go here tragic check check adhere one
can only delay checkmate they made for
one more move so we have one decisive
game in that in that first round with
Geary winning with black against Apollo
a game that probably would have ended in
a draw oops sorry would have ended in a
draw if not for the for the time trouble
here 94 was a very nice move by Geary I
mean it is some move that entails no
risk at all because well what takes in
to draw okay but Queen a7 is an
extremely tempting move and it's not
easy to spot why this shouldn't work I
mean okay you can you can say oh it's
the matter of the time
T'Pol off had two minutes um yeah okay
sometimes he has a problem of being a
little bit too ambitious in his in his
games on some decisions when he goes for
wind when this is not warranted I'm but
here like two minutes I don't know he
probably just miscalculated some
particular line maybe he thought that
something specific would work after
Queen d5 that did not work it's hard to
tell but a good job here buggery is the
only yet undefeated player in the grand
chester and still has chances to win the
overall event overall to earth I mean
and certainly nice for him to get a win
in ok I hope you enjoyed the coverage of
round one and i'll be back with the
round two coverage maybe even on the
saturday but at least an early early
Sunday european time thanks for watching